THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
PRESIDENT TRUMP CONFIRMING A
LARGE-SCALE IMMIGRATION
CRACKDOWN WILL BEGIN THIS
WEEKEND.
MAJOR CITIES PREPARING FOR
I.C.E. RAIDS ON SUNDAY.
THE PRESIDENT DEFENDING THE
OPERATION.
>> PEOPLE COME INTO OUR COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, WE ARE TAKING THEM
OUT LEGALLY.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE
DOING NOW IS THEY SHOULD BE
CHANGING THE LOOPHOLES.
THEY SHOULD BE CHANGING ASYLUMS.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
STANDING ONLINE WAITING FOR
THEIR CHANCE TO BE CITIZENS OF
THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS NOT FAIR THAT SOME BUT HE
WALKS ACROSS THE LINE AND NOW
THEY ARE CITIZENS.
THERE IS NOTHING TO BE SECRET
ABOUT.
IF THE WORLD GETS OUT, IT GETS
OUT.
WE ARE TAKING THEM OUT BY THE
THOUSANDS.
>> Juan: DEMOCRATS ARE FURIOUS
AT THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN,
NANCY PELOSI NOW BEING
CRITICIZED FOR GIVING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THIS ADVICE.
>> A I.C.E. DEPORTATION WARRANT
IS NOT THE SAME AS A SEARCH
WARRANT.
IF THAT IS THE ONLY DOCUMENT
I.C.E. BRINGS TO A HOME RAID,
AGENTS DO NOT HAVE THE LEGAL
RIGHT TO ENTER A HOME.
IF I.C.E. AGENTS DO NOT HAVE A
WARRANT SIGNED BY A JUDGE A
PERSON MAY REFUSE TO OPEN THE
DOOR AND LET THEM IN.
>> Juan: JOY BEHAR CAUSING
CONTROVERSY BY COMPARING THE
UPCOMING RAID TO WHAT HAPPENED
IN NAZI GERMANY.
>> TRUMP INTENDS TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH HIS IMMIGRATION RAIDS
TARGETING MIGRANT FAMILIES THIS
WEEKEND.
I THOUGHT THERE WERE GANGS FROM
THESE PLACES, NOT FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN.
HE IS GOING TO RAID THESE
PEOPLE'S HOUSES AND WHAT HAVE
YOU, AND IT IS REALLY
REMINISCENT OF NAZI GERMANY,
JUST SAYING.
>> Juan: THIS IS AN INTENSE
MOMENT, SO JESSE, LET'S JUST
START WITH THE NANCY PELOSI
ADVICE TO PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO RESPOND TO A SIMPLE
IMMIGRATION WARRANT, BUT THEY
NEED A SEARCH WARRANT TO OPEN
THE DOOR.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE
CONGRESSWOMAN SAYING DON'T
FOLLOW AND COMPLY WITH THE LAW
THAT CONGRESS PASSES.
EVERYTHING THAT IS HAPPENING
HERE IS COMPLETELY LEGAL.
IF YOU HAVE AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
CROSSING THE BORDER THAT GETS
CAUGHT BY BORDER PATROL YOU
DETAINED THEM AND THEY GET A
HEARING IN FRONT OF AN
IMMIGRATION JUDGE.
IF THEY APPLY FOR ASYLUM OR WANT
TO COME FOR WORK, THE JUDGE SAYS
YOU CAN STAY OR KNOW, AND ISSUES
DEPORTATION HEARING, PROCEEDING.
THEN I.C.E. WILL COME, BECAUSE
THEY DO INTERIOR ENFORCEMENT TO
A HOUSE AND APPREHEND AND
DEPORT.
THAT IS THE LAW THAT CONGRESS
PASSED YEARS AGO.
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH IS
ENFORCING THAT LAW.
AND THE JUDGES SIGNING OFF ON
EVERYTHING.
SO YOU HAVE EXECUTIVE JUDICIAL
AND LEGISLATIVE BRANCHES ALL
WORKING TOGETHER HARMONIOUSLY,
BUT YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS SAYING,
DON'T FOLLOW THE LAWS OF OUR
COUNTRY.
THEY WANT AMERICAN CITIZENS TO
FOLLOW THE LAWS, BUT THEY DON'T
WANT ILLEGAL ALIENS.
BUT YOU HAVE TO THINK, DO THEY
WANT ANY ENFORCEMENT?
THEY DO NOT WANT IT IN THE
INTERIOR OR AT THE BORDER, OR TO
STAY IN A COUNTRY THAT YOU ARE
AND APPLY.
WHEN YOU GET THERE, THEY DON'T
WANT YOU DETAINED.
IF YOU COMMIT A CRIME, THEY
DON'T WANT TO LET I.C.E. KNOW
ABOUT IT.
THEY DON'T EVEN WANT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ASK YOU A
QUESTION, ARE YOU A U.S.
CITIZEN?
BUT THEY WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
AMERICAN JOB, THEY WANT TO GIVE
YOU A DRIVER'S LICENSE, IN-STATE
COLLEGE TUITION AND FREE HEALTH
INSURANCE.
SO THE DEMOCRATS ARE THE PARTY
OF OPEN BORDERS AND THAT IS JUST
A FACT.
>> Juan: JUST A QUICK
QUESTION, ISN'T IT THE CASE THAT
SHE IS SAYING, HERE IS THE LAW
AS IT IS WITNESSED?
SHE IS NOT SAYING VIOLATES, SHE
IS SAYING FOLLOW THE LAW.
>> IF YOU ARE ISSUED A
DEPORTATION ORDER FROM A JUDGE
IN AMERICA, YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW
THAT ORDER.
>> Juan: WHAT WE ARE ALSO
SEEING IS THAT HILLARY CLINTON
AS WELL AS NANCY PELOSI ARE
SAYING, THIS IS PEOPLE GOING TO
CHURCH ON SUNDAY AND YOU'RE
BREAKING DOWN DOORS?
>> Dana: OKAY, GOT IT.
SO NEGLECTING TO ENFORCE THE LAW
FOR A COUPLE OF DECADES ON THE
USE ENFORCEMENT ORDERS MEANS
THAT THIS PROBLEM JUST GETS
HARDER.
AND UNLESS AMERICA IS GOING TO
SAY, OKAY, THEN EVERYBODY IS
HERE ILLEGALLY, YOU CAN STAY, IF
WE ARE GOING TO SAY THAT, WE
SHOULD HAVE THAT DEBATE.
AND THE LAWS WOULD HAVE TO
CHANGE.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY IS
ACTUALLY SAYING THAT.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, THAT IS
HURTING PEOPLE WHO WANT TO COME
HERE LEGALLY.
THE NUMBER OF STORIES WHO ARE
STUCK IN THE PROCESS AND THE
PAPERWORK BECAUSE THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET THEM HERE, WE NEED
PEOPLE TO COME HERE AND WORK AND
WANT TO RAISE THEIR FAMILIES
HERE, I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT LIKE
WITH WHAT JOY BEHAR SAID, IT IS
SO ATROCIOUS, BECAUSE JEWS WERE
TARGETED BECAUSE OF WHO THEY
WERE, NOT BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY
HAD DONE.
THESE WERE CITIZENS OF GERMANY,
THEY WERE PAYING TAXES,
COMPARING NAZI GERMANY TO THIS
IS REALLY BAD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO SAID TODAY,
WE ARE FOCUSED ON CRIMINALS AS
MUCH AS WE CAN.
AND I BELIEVE THAT, BECAUSE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
IS UNDER SUCH EXTREME SCRUTINY
TEA AND THEY HAVE TELEGRAPHED
FOR SIX WEEKS THAT THE RATES ARE
COMING, IMAGINE HOW EVERYONE IS
GOING TO BE OUT AND ABOUT IN THE
CITIES READY TO FILM ANYTHING TO
CATCH ANYTHING THAT MAKES IT
LOOK LIKE THEY ARE BEING
INSENSITIVE, AND IT WILL BE
HEART-WRENCHING, PEOPLE ARE HERE
FOR A LONG TIME, BUT IF THEY
COMMITTED A CRIME IN THE
UNITED STATES AND THEY HAVE A
DEPORTATION ORDER IN THE PRESENT
AND THE UNITED STATES DECIDES TO
EXECUTE, THEN THEY HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE LAW, FOR AS HARD AS
IT MIGHT BE TO WATCH, IT IS WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE PRIOR TO THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE NOT DONE IT
FOR DECADES MEANS LIKE IT GETS
WORSE THE LONGER WE DON'T DO IT.
>> Juan: WE HAD THE NEWS THAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT GOING TO
TRY TO CONTINUE THE EFFORT TO
PUT A QUESTION ABOUT CITIZEN
SHIP STATUS ON THE CENSUS, SO,
IS THIS NOW JUST A POLITICAL
STEP TO SAY, HEY, DEMOCRATS, YOU
BETTER GET ON BOARD AND START
DOING WHAT I WANT AND THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE GOING TO FEEL THE BRUNT
OF THIS OVER THE WEEKEND?
>> Greg: BEFORE I GO ANYWHERE
I WOULD LIKE TO BE SWORN IN.
I WANT TO BE SWORN IN, OKAY.
TO THE POINT ABOUT YESTERDAY OR
WHATEVER DAY IT WAS, I LOVE THIS
SOLUTION.
USING DATABASES THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE.
IT TOTALLY DESTROYS ALL OF THE
OBJECTIONS ABOUT OF VIOLATING
AND MAY BE MORE ACCURATE TO
ANSWERING THE CENSUS QUESTION.
THAT IS PRETTY BAD ASS.
HE IS NOT PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE IS
PRESIDENT McIVER.
HE HAS THE TOOLS AND ONLY
SOMEBODY IN BUSINESS UNDERSTANDS
THAT AND FOCUSES ON THE PROBLEM
FOR SO LONG AND HE SAYS I'LL GO
AROUND BACK AND FIX THIS MYSELF.
HE IS SOLVING THESE PROBLEMS
USING TWO KEY MOVERS IN HUMAN
NATURE.
ONE OF THEM IS FAIRNESS AND THE
OTHER IS INCENTIVE.
FAIRNESS, PEOPLE WHO DID IT THE
RIGHT WAY, PEOPLE WHO WAITED IN
LINE, IT IS NOT FAIR TO CUT IN
LINE.
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT.
ESPECIALLY MINORITIES WHO COME
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES WHO WAITED
IN LINE.
THE PROCESS MATTERS, BECAUSE
THEN EVERYBODY IS TREATED
FAIRLY.
THAT IS HUMAN NATURE, INCENTIVE.
WHAT HE IS DOING RIGHT NOW IS
PREDICATED ON THE REPUBLICAN
DISINCENTIVE.
WORD GETS OUT TO THAT WE ARE
GOING TO DEPORT PEOPLE WHO ARE
THERE ILLEGALLY, THIS
INCENTIVIZES PEOPLE FROM COMING
HERE.
IT IS THE OPPOSITE OF LEAVING
CARAVANS THROUGH, SO THESE ARE
TWO THINGS THAT HUMAN BEINGS
UNDERSTAND, FAIRNESS AND
INCENTIVE.
THESE ARE TWO THINGS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS CANNOT GET INTO THEIR
THICK SKULLS AND THAT'S WHY THEY
ARE LOSING THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
AND DEVOURING THEMSELVES.
AND NOW I WOULD LIKE TO BE SWORN
IN.
>> Juan: EMILY, ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS IS IF YOU
ARE GOING AFTER PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED AND HAVE NOT SHOWN
UP FOR COURT DATES, IS IT
POSSIBLE TO SWEEP UP PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN LIVING HERE, FAMILIES
TOGETHER, DONE NOTHING WRONG,
PAYING TAXES AND WORKING, THEY
ARE GOING TO GET SWEPT UP IN ALL
OF THE ACTIVITY THIS WEEKEND.
>> Emily: I THINK IT IS TRUE
AND UNRELATED, IF YOU MEAN SWEPT
UP, THEY ARE PART OF THE
DEPORTATION ORDER, THAT IS THE
WHOLE POINT.
TO RESPOND TO WHAT BOTH OF YOU
GUYS WERE SAYING, I THINK THE
OUTCRY OVER THE ENFORCEMENT OF
THE EXISTING LAWS IGNORES THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE BUILT IN
SAFETY FEATURES WITHIN THE
PROCESS ITSELF, THE FINAL
DEPORTATION ORDER MEANS THAT ALL
APPEALS HAVE BEEN EXHAUSTED.
EVEN IF THE IMMIGRANTS JUST
RESERVED THE RIGHT TO APPEAL,
THAT TAKES THE ENTIRE
PROCEEDING.
THERE ARE MORE SAFETY FEATURES
BUILT IN, ARE WE CALLING INTO
QUESTION THE JUDGES ORDER, THE
JUDGE'S JUDGMENT?
THE POLICIES, THE 90 DAYS THAT
I.C.E. HAS TWO DEPORT?
LET'S CHANGE IT, CONGRESSPEOPLE
OR VOTERS OR WHAT ELSE DO OUR
TAX DOLLARS PAY FOR?
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
IF NOT 1 MILLION THAT ARE HERE
WITH FINAL DEPORTATION ORDERS
FOR US.
FOR US TO IGNORE THAT OR FOR US
TO PICK AND CHOOSE WHAT LAWS WE
WANT TO ENFORCE, WHY THEN WOULD
WE NOT PICK AND CHOOSE EVERY
OTHER LAW, SO WHEN YOU SAY THAT
IT IS UP TO US TO BASICALLY
EXEMPLIFY A MODEL WHAT IS GOING
ON, ABSOLUTELY, BECAUSE WHAT
MESSAGE ARE WE SENDING?
I WOULD THINK THAT IT WOULD BE A
COMMENT ON ALL OF US TO
APPRECIATE THAT, BECAUSE THE
REST OF US THAT ARE HERE SHOULD
KNOW THAT OUR GOVERNMENT DOES
PRIORITIZE ENFORCING LAWS,